probably the most common form of
transportation in Haiti is the tap tap
and this is char Louie that's a great
name Charlie goes I wish my name was
Charlie United States we call this a cab
here we call it tap tap okay
and so they just tap on the side of our
vehicle is that right exactly when
someone which you stop you um yeah Bob
stop but usually we have somebody with
me to collect their money I can collect
the money I'm with you don't trust me
just with you I'll count the money what
if I take more than my share well that's
between you in your pawn shops because
if you are with man supposed to trust
you
means that I bring to light and joy
entire nation what do you yell at people
in a team league to fool your fufufu
what does that mean I've made you crazy
crazy fool ya fool you fool Perry you
have eight children yes God my god the
stool ah do you have time to write the
tab what are these this is the most
generic way this is a business no we're
not making any business so I'm gonna get
him back and try and get us some
business okay we've had no luck packing
up anyone I think something about me
looks untrustworthy here in Haiti so now
I have a sign that says being probably
would you like a free ride in probably
three right be right
three like three right yeah come on in
yes hey how are you you speak some
English little bit what's your name
Giovanni you from here from live in
Haiti would you like a free ride I don't
care
we'll take you here house don't worry
we'll take you to your house how close
is your house so we're headed the wrong
way from your house it's free it's free
come on in come on in
yes oh okay
you okay hello hello bushwa so what do
you do yeah
[Applause]
crazy that's fantastic thank you now
what is cocoa mean someone told me it
doesn't mean meaning right now woman the
woman's vagina smell it's at our card
you smell that I think we're burning out
our transmission
we're gonna okay here's what's going on
our tap tap died and now we're stuck up
against this car that was our driver
okay I don't want to do in a panic but
our driver just went that way
[Music]
everyone sings for
United States everybody would be
shilling everybody 35 bucks at me here
people are like this is light we're
gonna deal with it we're gonna get
through it okay someone's getting out of
my tap top because the clutch burned out
on this hill I apologize I'm gonna get
you out something I guess you know I'm
gonna get to home but I want to thank
you for being such a supporter of mine
and I'm my I picked that laptop I want
to thank you for giving you this team
cocoa shirt
[Applause]
you